merci l'ordre du jour appelle les
questions au gouvernement la parole est
à monsieur guillaume chevrollier merci
monsieur le président ma question
s'adresse à monsieur le premier ministre
monsieur le premier ministre le déficit
commercial de la france est repartie à
la hausse l'an dernier
encore une mauvaise nouvelle économique
il s'établit à 48,1 milliards dépassant
très nettement vos prévisions
les conditions étaient pourtant
favorables avec la baisse de l'euro et
une diminution de plus de 8 milliards de
la facture énergétique
les exportations ont diminué en dépit de
gros contrats comme les ventes
d'armements qui ont rapporté 20
milliards d'euros
cette dégradation est préoccupante elle
montre combien votre gouvernement a été
incapable de donner à nos entreprises
le soutien et la confiance nécessaires
après un début de quinquennat qui n'a
été que ponction et impôts votre
gouvernement a institué le cic un
système compliqué lourd et à effet non
immédiat au lieu de procéder aux baisses
de charges que nous proposions notre
agriculture a également été touché de
plein fouet avec une baisse des
exportations mais aussi avec une hausse
conséquente des importations qui
mécontente légitimement nos agriculteurs
dans le contexte de crise qu'il traverse
ce déficit commercial illustre les
problèmes de notre industrie et la
dégradation de la situation des services
et chiffres montrent combien la
compétitivité de la france est atteinte
d'autant plus que nos voisins européens
eux ont su réagir comme l'espagne ou
l'allemagne dont l'excédent commercial
excédent commercial a atteint 234
milliards d'euros c'est donc un constat
d'échec magistrale de votre majorité et
de tous vos ministre de l'économie dont
je tairai la longue liste
nous nous pouvons que souhaiter
l'alternance pour notre pays
l'alternance seul capable d'apporter le
redressement économique dont la france a
besoin
il est temps de redonner la liberté le
souffle indispensable à notre pays en
conclusion monsieur le premier ministre
un vrai projet de ce type au rôle et à
monsieur mathias felk elle
secrétaire d'état chargée du commerce
extérieur de la promotion du tourisme et
des français de l'étranger
merci monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les députés monsieur le député
chevreuils et si vous le permettez je
veux d'abord m'associer à l'émotion vous
avez exprimé sur le président est
souhaitée à monsieur gaudin le meilleur
rétablissement possible et ce le plus
vite possible et à mon tour penser à ses
proches nous l'apprécions nous le
connaissons et nous espérons pouvoir le
voir bientôt à nouveau ici sur le
commerce extérieur
j'ai eu l'occasion exprimé hier à
l'occasion de la présentation des
chiffres je les fais à plus de 20
reprises devant le parlement pour
présenter systématiquement à l'évolution
des choses les chiffes pour 2016
vous avez raison ne sont pas bons nous
constatons une dégradation de la balance
commerciale à 48 milliards d'euros est
également une dégradation de la balance
des services que pour la deuxième fois
depuis l'an dernier nous présentons
ensemble pour avoir la vraie approche de
la réalité de notre pays et de son
insertion dans la mondialisation 48
milliards d'euros de déficit sur les
biens et nous sommes à peu près à
l'équilibré sur les services après un
excédent l'an dernier de plus de 8
milliards principalement à cause de
l'évolution du tourisme ce que vous
oubliez de dire en revanche monsieur le
député je le regrette
c'est lorsque nous sommes arrivés au
pouvoir le déficit était à plus de 70
milliards d'euros un tiers du déficit a
été résorbé pendant ce quinquennat alors
que la part de marché française n'a
cessé de s'éroder à plus de 5% au début
des années 2000 et une érosion
permanente tout au long des dix années
de pouvoir de la droite
nous avons assisté sous ce quinquennat à
une stabilisation de la part de marché
de nos entreprises françaises dans le
monde à trois et demi pour cent si on
prend la moyenne ce sont des succès de
diplomatie économique le nombre
d'entreprises exportatrices n'a cessé
d'augmenter
117 1000 en 2011 124 mille l'an dernier
donc il y à des situations difficiles
un effort de redressement à poursuivre
mais aussi des éléments de stabilité et
une diplomatie économique qui a répondu
présent tout au long de ces années
mais